I'm still having a lot of issues with panic attacks. They stop for a handful of days
but then they come back with a vengeance. I can't figure out why as I'm taking all the things
you recommended, wondering if doing a neurotransmitter panel would help. Yeah, we can do a neurotransmitter panel.
That's a possibility. I do think doing a Cyrix 7x would be in order. That's to see if you have
antibodies to neural tissue, I think that would be the most appropriate one. If you do a neurotransmitter
panel, they're not super accurate tests because neurotransmitters are not just used in your brain.
So neurotransmitters are used at all your synapses of all your nerves, which is all over your body.
So it's not just measuring brain neurotransmitter function. So you're better off finding out why you
have inflammation in the brain and doing a Cyrix 7x. So I'm not opposed if you're wanting to do a
neurotransmitter panel. So contact me and we could get that ordered.